thank you
[Music]
let's do a little roll call in the realm
Zach Riley what's going on what's going
on Christopher Hardy here early
what's going on what's going on Leo lion
talk to me live Supremacy what's going
on man
[Music]
let me know how the levels are sounding
Robert Kelly what's going on oh Zach
said it sounded good sounding good
that's what I want to hear that's what I
hear best of sounded in ages all right
all right I'm feeling brand new right
now casino is going over over now
Christopher are you ain't slick I see
you we got all we got so much to talk
about today
you fancy I had to do a mic check right
quick
[Music]
the legend coming through Mr Patrick
Wren talking that respawn talk Talking
that Jedi Survivor talk we got a lot to
get into but we're gonna get him in here
we're gonna get King up here it's gonna
be fun we got topics after so that
should be going so I'll see y'all in a
bit
laughs
you hear you man welcome to the show if
you would not mind go hit it up find
yourself a spot get comfortable grab a
snack do all the good stuff that we need
to do in um you know we're about to get
started I am well it's not important who
I am uh what's important is that you are
pulling up to the iron Lords podcast
right now as we speaking uh I guess I'm
here to keep you entertained until it's
time to get this show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers they don't want to be on the
song with me that's understandable I
kill a beating they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all too
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and snapping and
making it flammable this is that this is
that Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just a Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start regardless
and people don't aim check my vocals all
on Twitter but I'm anti-social or my
city but I'm still by Coastal I got it
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be using these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and sampling making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting the rains you just a
Target when I'm in the range I was the
hardest to start with regardless back
when you with messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter social or
my city but I'm still by Coastal I got
it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to Freddy
and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal they'd
be like why use a video game just be
original you're also Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting them Reigns
you just to Target when I'm in the range
I was the hardest to start with
regardless back when you was messaging
people don't aim check my vocals all on
Twitter but a man's social knowing my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
because it's pretty hard to sleep on
Freddy Krueger that's oh
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
am look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and headers be swearing that
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they wanna compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and Sample and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's Arsen up in
the apartment they call a department and
I get the flame still I'll be running
collecting them Reigns you just a Target
when I'm in the range I was the hardest
to start regardless like we was
messaging people on AIM check my vocals
all on Twitter but I'm anti-social
knowing my city but I'm still by Coastal
I got you man
[Music]
that's
who
let's do that again
foreign
man welcome to the show if you would not
mind go hit it up find yourself a spot
get comfortable grab a snack do all that
good stuff that we need to do in um you
know we're about to get started I am
well it's not important who I am uh
what's important is that you are pulling
up to the iron Lords podcast right now
as we speaking uh I guess I'm here to
keep you entertained until it's time to
get this show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
Freddy and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all for Dramatical I know
it's random but I'm addicted to flipping
and sampling making it flammable this is
that this is the Yoga Fire Flame they
think it's Arsen up in the apartment
they call a department and I get the
blame still I'll be running collecting
them Reigns you just a Target when I'm
in the range I was the hardest to start
regardless back when you was messaging
people on AIM check my vocals all on
Twitter but I'm anti-social lower my
city but I'm still by Coastal
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell her Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important to who I am uh what's
important is that you are pulling up to
the iron Lords podcast right now as we
speaking uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
down look y'all messed up and turned me
to an animal and headers be swearing
ain't real but coming to find out that
they really mechanical and yeah I'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being a cannibal and they say
I'm better than money because you can
Bank on me being accountable I know a
million rappers that don't want to be on
a song with me that's understandable I
kill a beat and they want to compare me
to Freddie and Jason I'd rather be
Hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original you're also
Dramatical I know it's random but I'm
addicted to flipping and Snapple and
making it flammable this is that this is
the Yoga Fire Flame they think it's
Arsen up in the apartment they call a
department and I get the blame still
I'll be running collecting the rains you
just a Target when I'm in the range I
was the hardest to start regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but I'm
anti-social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal
[Music]
that's
do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headers be swearing it real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah I'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say I'm better
than money because you can Bank on me
being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable I kill a
beating they want to compare me to
Freddie and Jason I'd rather be Hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original you're also Dramatical I
know it's random but I'm addicted to
flipping and snapping and making it
flammable this is that this is that Yoga
Fire Flame they think it's arson up in
the apartment they call it department
and I get the blame still I'll be
running collecting them Reigns you just
to Target when I'm in the range I was
the hardest to start it regardless back
when you was messaging people on AIM
check my vocals all on Twitter but a man
time social or my city but I'm still by
Coastal I got it
[Music]
never been a loser making Voltron with a
gang of cougars and I'm going places
better tell an Uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on Freddy Krueger that's
who
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go hit it up
find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all the good stuff that
we need to do in um you know we're about
to get started I am well it's not
important who I am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
Lords podcast right now as we speaking
uh I guess I'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being a cannibal and they say I'm
better than money because you can Bank
on me being accountable I know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable
[Music]
foreign
detrimental to an elemental what's an
avatar to a knee vendor I gotta be Neato
I know it's my destiny work to carnido
who cares if you fly if you steal a
mosquito you swear you ain't nothing but
really be Stevo you like to collect
stuff and that's cool but I got bad news
even if you really was that joke King
David still be the king of the statue
sister juvenile I've been cursed with a
curse to be Musical and if you hate it
we'll meet in The Crucible other than
nothing it's cool and it's beautiful we
let you know that your dreams are
pursuable whatever you want to do then
it's doable if you got work on a Sunday
it's suitable cause you can listen to
this in your cubicle on the Lord day
[Music]
three radio
hey all right my check my check and talk
to the people right can you give me a
little mic check there I'm I'm taking my
focus oh you forgot you plug in early
got to be focused today got to be on
here we got to be focused they got a
legend in the building we got Lord
Patrick we just got a little mic check
from you right quick how we how are we
saying it oh you sounded good you
sounded glorious yeah it sounded like a
chat out of me right now I'm rocking
that bed in the game by the way
[Laughter]
and we all live welcome to the iron
launch podcast LLC and also live on
lordsofgaming.net episode number 302.
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the round table on the Lord's date
and today I'm extremely excited about
our special guest and we've got respawn
into David and Star Wars Jedi survival
CMA blocking Microsoft's avk deal okay
Aces rag I'll call it the rock even
though it it's like it's the Rog Cog I'm
Cog I'm calling it The Rock Rock Allied
to discuss so we gonna get right into it
I want to introduced the Lord whose
passage for video games and pop culture
is only matched by his technical Acumen
in both single player and addicting
multiplayer sandboxes this launch career
has recently respawned into a studio who
in my opinion has never made a single
bad game
and tradition the senior encounter
designer at respawn entertainment and
the former senior multiplayer designer
at 343
the Lord of calcasus and bd1
who hilarious made us all fret in Halo
infinite multiplayer it is still one
half of Gaming's royal power couple with
Lady Rachel
live from Washington and making his
triumphant return into the realm of the
Lord my man Lord Patrick Wren of respawn
entertainment how we doing sir
in your realm of game development is
only right we show you the proper
respect here in the round table how you
doing has it has it set in the release
of or your work is is out in the wild
and how's it feeling right now it's
feeling really good
um it's it's been an insane week you
know a lot of anxiousness and hype and
energy but uh you know besides some of
the obvious that yes people have been
talking about you know it's it's it's
great to see the game out there and
people resonating with it so yeah good
to hear man good to hear obviously you
know a big launch it's got to be
anticipation and obviously since last
time you've been here some Life Changes
a wedding happened in the the Royal the
Royal Wedding went down you know how's
things been in the household now oh it's
been great you know
so what happens when you you know marry
your best friend you know it's like
nothing changes and everything changes
all at once so it's been good to salute
the bungee in the building no doubt and
you already know we got some Horsemen
coming through this this one Horseman on
Route and one Horseman missing let's see
if uh one of Lord addict is is the on
Route still available or are you still
he's still in traffic I don't know if
he's home yet I can still talk I'm just
not gonna talk much
until I get home you won't hear much
from me I'll be home in like five ten
minutes but uh yeah definitely looking
forward to it no doubt no doubt you
already know we have uh those other
horsemen first of all we gotta say that
I love y'all legit this is real this is
real there's no cap on this one no cap
on this one we gotta set our love to our
brother Lord solve you know it's a loss
of the family and he's going to address
some stuff so he really wanted to be
here obviously you know him not being
here he's got to be serious so send some
legit love flood his timeline him and
his brother there's a loss of the family
and we miss you brother and we know
you're gonna take care of business we're
gonna hold you down and have some fun
hopefully when you come back so so go
check him out right there so um yeah
then we got my co-host the combos in
traffic my brother from another mother
the difficult game conqueror Lord of his
own world and the how of the young wolf
Lord addict on the move of the attic
show I'll be doing real quickly
doing pretty good that's all that's my
intro today
on the Run attic on the Run
I liked it like it's a series
I just don't want to devalue our audio a
lot I respect that no doubt no doubt we
got the Doppler Chopper yeah
how's the traffic going on IE I-95 okay
we got a pickup truck Speed Run 92 yo
Attic in the air no doubt and of course
we have the Incredible Hulk of this aka
the access gamer the prophet of Xbox
Swami King of the statues who demands
nothing less than that premium
experience it is the leader of the fraud
alert movement
beloved Lord King how are we doing sir
doing better than Microsoft at the
moment
is kind of crazy over there
uh yeah man
um
I'm gonna get to what I was playing
because okay we're gonna get to
everything else but what I've been
playing this week has been great first
I've been playing
um Jedi Survivor now I went back to Jedi
falling all the thinking yo I got I
gotta clear this up because you know we
got to play Jedi uh Survivor you know we
having the dev on uh I gotta I gotta get
it together I got it in um falling order
I'm looking around I'm like what I got
to do what plan I gotta go to there was
no waypoints
and it was like a new game plus played
over here I was like ah in the day
did it already jump right into Survivor
and I was just like oh snap so we're
gonna get to the old snap moments
because this is a lot that I can talk
about with that
um definitely saw me playing fortnite uh
and also I uh I downloaded blue blaze uh
the tag team
um fighting game that just came out
animated fighting game
I I
it has to be some type of Renaissance
with fighting games right now because I
have at least seven fighting games
downloaded that came out within the last
four months from my Xbox and I'm playing
in between like Jojo oh yeah blue blaze
just just so many games I'm like wow
this this
um what is it um
not fatal Fury uh the Neo Geo game
Fighters you're King of the fighters
we're all all the fighters yo I'm just
like it's taking me back and I can see
the competition because I'm playing a
couple of online games I mean online
matches and dudes are really in and
Street Fighter is gonna probably be the
icing on the cake
[Music]
but this year because that looked good I
wasn't gonna play the beta I wasn't
gonna do the beta boys with the street
fighter okay you're gonna wait you're
gonna wait for the finished product dude
yeah the situation yeah no no brainer I
did play a little bit with pack but we
had to do that for y'all guys just let
y'all know how the gameplay but I want
to play that in the house because the
story mode and everything I downloaded
uh Benedict Fox oh nice and
what happened is I downloaded both of
the Jedi Survivor and that at the same
time so my plan was to play Jedi
Survivor and play a little bit of better
than Fox
it was crazy it was on from there but um
yeah that's all I've been playing this
week no doubt no doubt and of course we
have the gaming ninja himself the
Shinobi Lord Cognito spreading real into
the rum and IOP not telling what you
want to hear but what you need to hear
shout out to Friday dude shout out to my
man Mr batty plays had a good discussion
on blockings of of deals and we'll get
into a little bit of that later also we
got some really special uh definitely do
ultimate interviews coming up stay tuned
that'll be real cool shout out to the
last word my brothers he bought this to
I got Travis talk about the latest
that's going on in Destiny you know what
I mean and what's going on with the uh
the next season that could be coming up
and Guardian Games they're doing some
fun things class versus class which
you're getting excited about and then
for me I actually fired up earlier in
the week uh Battlefield 2048 I've been
on the season four I got a friend they
fixed a lot like it's actually really
changed an old Battlefield kind of three
energy that I have before energy that I
used to like too so the class system is
back the what is it that the little um
the the weather changing event what they
used to call it Revolution they got that
kind of thing going on yo I was like yo
it's actually in a really good state
right now you do that for Community Day
yeah listen I'm down to do it and it's
in Game Pass King ain't no excuse you
know how you do it yeah yeah you know
the cake is interesting now yeah
if it's not a game pass I didn't hear it
fall
yeah ain't no doubt so we got that and
then um obviously I did my refresher
Jedi Fallen order first and it was
really really good to to get back into
that narratively just to see where Cal
was his journey was all the things and
allies along the way wait so did you did
you finish the first one you know what's
funny I did but I just forgot certain
key points so I just wanted to go
through real quick so I had like a
halfway playthrough on the New Game Plus
or whatever so I was like let me go
through again but yeah that was it was a
real Touch of story so what's funny is
jumping into now you know Survivor so
fresh right after like you see the jump
substantially I'm like oh yeah we're
gonna get to that yeah we're gonna get
to that because I was like what nobody
to talk about like for me listen I cut
my talk
about the old ones
yes yes it's correct yeah correct you're
absolutely right you're absolutely my
biggest question was when I went back
into the game
I said where they go where they gonna
take me after I don't [__] fader like
this you know but I'm saying
right and it was like yeah new game plus
that's where we taking you because it
was over I was like oh yeah man yeah
so that's where pretty much that we were
talking to our stuff but uh okay man
nothing on your switch oh no nothing
nothing
yeah you know what I noticed because
here we go I like to grab the frauds and
grab them up I grab I like I like that I
like to shake the frauds out you're
ridiculous because since I've noticed
since your steam that hit it ain't even
been no switch coming in hot well it
hasn't been no switch
there's a certain uh individual dropping
a game this okay just me yeah let's see
let's see what happens let's see what
happens what happens here tears of the
Kingdom goes down um
the the fraud stealing oh you don't
anyway
we gotta pay the bills right quick with
some sweet talk okay today's episode is
sponsored by PayPal honey the easy way
to say when shopping on your iPhone or
computer have you been feeling the
impact of inflation what's the craziest
price hike you've noticed for food or
gas with these high prices skyrocketing
everywhere how does it feel whatever you
do find that magical deal is it exciting
is it a relief well thanks to Honey
mainly searching for coupon codes is a
thing of the past honey is the free
shopping tool that scours the internet
for promo codes and applies the best
what it finds to your car so this is how
it works Lords imagine you're shopping
in one of your favorite websites when
you check out the honey button appears
and all you have to do is Click apply
coupons wait a few seconds as honey
searches for coupons they can find for
that website the funny finds a working
coupon you'll watch the prices just drop
I put firstly use honey all the time
when I'm shopping for my gaming gear or
the latest tech or game Linux um
accessories I recently saved like 15
went up got a brand new Elite Series 2
controller and was surprised to see how
easy it was to use the only notification
popped up immediately at checkout show
me that I could save the money right
then and there did you know honey
doesn't just work on the desktop it
works on the iPhone too you can activate
it on Safari on your phone and save on
the go if you don't already have honey
you could be straight up missing out and
by getting it you'll be doing yourself a
solid and supporting this show so get
PayPal honey for free at joinhoney.com
iron Lords that's joinhoney.com
iron Lords so I'm done with my fakes off
Impressions and and all the sweet talk
double pressure on me
you got you got to get out there y'all
you gotta support the show you know what
I'm saying use honey
no doubt no doubt so look we're gonna
get into it now look I would apologize
in advance because obviously solve is um
not here and an Atticus on the race so
the super chat's gonna just find the
rules of engagement super chats will
read after you know I'm saying Lord
Patrick unfortunately because we gotta
respect his time and I gotta respect
everything else that's going on but um
now that we got into all that business
and sweet talk and all that stuff we
gotta talk about our special guest we
got to talk about Lord Patrick red you
know what I'm saying his recent journey
to Reese wanted to tame it being a Star
Wars fan and of course what led him to
now being Cena senior design director at
Star Wars
so look real quickly also a large if you
want to know his illustrious gaming
history remember King he had that game
gear talk he had yeah we could have
talked to go check out IOP episode 214
where you can really get into the game
what we want to talk about now is kind
of briefly this transition when you this
recent career opportunity get to respawn
what's it like to be a day in the life
of a design director and then as far as
you know just for anyone who doesn't
know what that entails what's the
lifeline for senior encounter designer
encounter designer correct sorry that's
correct you're correct yes gotta keep
you on your gotta keep you on my toes
yeah uh encounter design is a it's
really it's really fun
um basically any
non-bosses in our game so any enemy
composition anything that you're
fighting is what the encounter team does
got it okay so we work with the the
level design team uh they're designing
like the level flow and level layout
puzzles you know working with narrative
and all of that and we're figuring out
you know where different combat
opportunities can be that kind of metal
gameplay and story to you know make the
experience better so a lot of it is you
know
how
coming up with the idea you know placing
some guys down testing things out
getting a feel it's like is this the
direction we want to go and then start
iterating you know scripting adding more
scripting to like really making it
special so it's a it's a lot of fun nice
nice so I get to blame you for that
first jump scare around that corner that
okay so it's a that was my co-workers
it was a very specific Corner very early
on in the game and I come around the
corner and the monster just leaps out of
me made me scream and I ran forward I
didn't even understand the fight I
turned around I almost had to jumped out
but that was a good placement in that
area so encounters was oh yeah that's
good good placement so doubt no doubt
and I gotta ask you know obviously I'll
be a huge fan of freeze form so I gotta
ask you know um what's it like working
with uh one of the Legends in the game I
consider one of the Legends again Lord
Vince San Pella you get a chance to
interact with him at all obviously he's
a lot of history in the gaming business
yeah I think I haven't interacted with
Vince directly but I mean he's in you
know every company meeting every team
meeting he he's someone that has his
finger on the pulse and is
like someone who he's he's amazed like I
I've really respected like all of his
views and all the decisions he's made
like yeah Vince is awesome salute the
Lord Vince you already know now I want
to talk about kind of like the early
game development for you guys you know
for you and the team obviously you know
you're not kind of working on the first
game but like what was your connection
if any to fall in order the original and
then what was some of the things like
maybe the team wanted to address or
complaints you wanted to to get at when
designing but getting into the
encounters and stuff of this game
yeah um
yeah so I I joined in last year that's
correct why or no
it's two years ago yeah I'd love to say
that was two years the end of yeah the
end of 2021
um so
you know the the team you know had a
good handle on where things were you
know we're still had a lot of games make
but uh
the great thing was in my interview I I
asked that the same question because I
like to kind of see when I'm joining a
company it's like you know how are you
taking learnings and growing and um for
encounters there's a lot of making sure
the world felt more lived in the
characters and once you go into a space
like you know you know everyone knows
that Star Wars feel oh yes Skybox yeah
and there's definitely a lot of that in
fall and Order and a lot of awesome
things but you know there's some stuff
where like characters would stand around
a little bit more you know there wasn't
as much staging and when you're coming
in of stuff all the time and that was
something we really wanted to address to
nice really make something react nice no
no that's really really informed we got
uh resident lordsofgaming.net writer my
man senior edit what's going on uh Lord
God I just want to do a mic check right
quick make sure you sounded okay how do
I sound sounding
that's what I'm talking about so yeah I
just wanted to you know obviously I'm
assuming addict and Lord Gondor have the
most hours out of all of us so let's
actually uh pitch actually pitch it to
King first because I just wanted to not
a king has kind of you know played a bit
I think me and you have the least hours
but out of the crew you know say as far
as the new one but like what's your your
Fields any questions you had for Laura
Patrick at first just about that achieve
getting into Survivor well okay
knowing that uh where his level of
expertise is uh first I'm gonna give
High Praise to the game for
just it feels at least two times more
than the last game if that was ever
possible in the beginning of the first
game I noticed how expansive it looked
um how detailed the graphics were uh how
good the animations were I did have a
nitpick with the animations of Cal while
he was running in the first game and the
second game seemed to address that with
you know he's a more mature Jedi he's a
little bit uh deeper into the force at
this period of time
he's just looking more of um like like
he grows into his man strength and his
confidence as far as the force goes and
stuff like that but the world the
Aesthetics I'm looking at the these
monolithic um architectures that's like
in the back that it had a real Star Wars
film
it felt uh because you know Star Wars uh
lived in the Machine World and analog
world there's not really so much digital
and it gives it an analog feel to it
right so it gives it an old VHS feel but
it's supposed to be future Tech and the
first game felt a little bit Barren when
you went to certain worlds this
feels like lived in the first planet
that I'm at the first town that I got to
it felt really lived in the world the
details and the grass the foliage is
three times more uh the the architecture
on the walls and and the level design is
you have different paths I've noticed
this is my question to you Patrick like
when they gave you the the layout
and I know you didn't work on the first
game the first game really had one or
two paths to get to set objective
is this a lot harder dealing with the
fact that you have at least six or seven
paths to get to the main objective and
you had to design encounters around the
possibilities of individuals going to
their objective like to get to the town
I know I had like at least eight
different ways to get to the town
yeah I mean a big objective to this game
is player expression and exploration and
how do you want to approach situations
right what you you just talked about
um in a you know the biggest challenge
is we could put encounters everywhere in
like chocolate stuff but like that gets
really tiring and repetitive after a
while so it's a lot of
you know where is a cool place to put
something that makes sense that is
really engaging and you know builds the
world out instead of just you know
putting just putting a bunch of guys for
you to fight through so it's been it's
been fun trying to figure out like you
know
what what that balance is
um
real quick I just want to tell the chat
we're not going to spoil anything relax
I keep seeing no spoilers spoilers
and the noise
I have one more question good
all right it's being that you controller
encounters did y'all and did you control
the banter like because a lot of times
you you'll hear a banter from another
room you're in one room and you're here
some some people talking in the next
room and you just don't want to break
the conversation so you want to creep up
just enough to listen you know it's an
encounter that's going to happen but the
conversations is so funny before you get
to set encounter was y'all in control of
that aspect as well
uh it was a partnership between us and
the narrative team nice okay
um you know when after what you like
kind of do our passive gameplay feel you
know we start working with like okay you
know where do we want certain character
moments like where do we want the player
to kind of pay attention to and so we
work really closely with the narrative
team to kind of choose which characters
you know are gonna be that kind of
guiding like that moment I love the fact
that like jetters are so rare now
that the enemy forgot how beastly they
are they're like you'll be thinking
about them like that Jedi shows up he's
done like like they they can't you can't
who who why is everyone running from him
and then he shows up and like uh the
only thing I kind of would have wanted
is like some
fear in the occasionally because I feel
like like other games do it really well
I think like Shadow Mordor like where if
you kill like a leader or something like
the rest run it's like but then uh you
know a lot of them are clones so they
probably ain't even really have the
willpower to be able to run like that
too so definitely you know what's funny
though but it's like part of me the
charm of the like the Star Wars star
trooper it's kind of being an idiot and
like thinking like when you deflected uh
you know your Lifesaver against them and
killed like three and they still like I
still got a shot
I think it's part of the job of their
foolishness but I know what you're
saying as far as like as a gen like they
should be out like they they should
you have no problems like sticking enemy
factions against empty factions
sometimes I would be rolling up and
they'd be fighting each other yes and
the thing I want to give credit as far
as from the ability standpoint you know
one of the things that really changes
that Advocate again to me is the like
the Jedi buying trick right so now you
you ending in kind of like okay I'm
getting overwhelmed I'm gonna send you
over there to get this one right and
then I could focus on maybe long
distance combat and things of that
nature and that you really start to
strategize you know what I'm saying
especially the stances and like
encounters with all the new mechanics
added really added added Dimension I
want to give kudos to the team on that
one it really feels good and good on you
guys for being able to like
Implement stances without making any of
them feel like mandatory like I ain't
using the stances I use base Jedi stairs
with just one lightsaber uh I did use
one of the unlockable ones I don't want
to ruin that one but uh it that that was
my favorite by far especially like
dueling people one-on-one with Savers
because because it would it would be a
frontward guard and I I love that one I
didn't really stick anything after that
I I unlocked that one no that little guy
I know any questions for for Laura
Patrick in reference to your experiences
so far yeah so uh for the viewers
watching at home so far I have about 13
hours into the game uh and so I've
gotten more than a strong enough deal of
like how the various stances work
however like since you are an encounter
designer I did want to ask you about the
various nuances the encounters you work
on differ uh
so like I really wanted to know about
like how much uh goes into designing
like a narrative based encounter as
opposed to an open world encounter that
you might not run into if you're just
mainlining the game
yeah that's a great question
um
for the one thing that you kind of have
an advantage of with like a side
encounter is
it's more about what point is what do
you want this to be kind of like a fun
thing or do you want it to be like this
is your your challenge right if you
wanna because like you said not
everyone's gonna experience it so for
the people who do you know what kind of
experience you want to give them we're
with story stuff you know there's a lot
of very important pacing and difficulty
curves and things because you want it to
be an engaging experience and but we
also don't want to be too easy and
boring but we don't want to be learned
frustrating so there's a lot more very
specific balance that goes into
um the overall game when you're doing a
story encounter where a side content can
be very like focused on its own balance
yeah uh and like bouncing off of the
like various encounter types uh when
you're uh design like stuff that you'll
definitely find when you're mainlining
uh how often does it swing between how
often did you feel that you got the
chance to swing between uh something
that specifically had to tie into the
narrative and something that you were
given an area to make something happen
but got to add your own creativity to it
um I mean it's a great question
um I think this kind of goes to talking
a little bit about you know team
structure and team makeup especially on
our team at refund where everyone is
really empowered to put their mark on
the game and you know I worked really
close like I said really closely with
all these other teams and you know I got
a lot of opportunity and freedom to
pitch ideas to them to build cool things
that fit together so you know there were
certain things that were
like hey we need this to be for this
specific story moment but a lot more was
a lot more collaborative and really a
lot more open within within a box right
you know we had our constraints of what
we're trying to do but within that you
know we're allowed to do pretty much
anything
so you still kind of had that creativity
you know and it's not just locked in
because I thought it might be difficult
with like you know maybe you obviously
gotta you got the lore you got to
respect that and then you got you know
the whole overarching ethos of of the
narrative and things of that nature but
it's interesting to see that you can
kind of you know put that together still
have put your little individuality and
feel into it you know as far as the
question I've always wanted to ask I
don't know if this is specifically
related to your team but like one thing
I always thought interesting was uh with
uh with Jedi falling order and Survivor
is what I call the the classic between
encounter where you you know callous
sliding in between the wall but I had to
give you guys credit normally those are
like super boring to me but the way you
guys do it like like BD will hop up you
know move his legs actually say in terms
of set pieces
Survivor is like up there of Naughty
Dogs
yeah there's this one particular where
you team up with something and like the
set piece is just insane like absolutely
Bonkers I wanted to comment on that but
again I don't know if that's your team
but it definitely leads to the encounter
then I don't know like talk to me about
that because people like oh it's just a
loading but I feel you guys are really
creative in that aspect about it yeah
because
you know this is a
20 to 50 hour game is you know people
are kind of finding out depending on how
much they want to try 100 it or just
Mainline it so like when we're building
stuff we're always looking at you know
what what serves the player as they're
going through this what keeps it
interesting keeps engaging gives them
the breath you know so like yeah we're
like every enemy placement like we are
thinking about like there's nothing
that's just like oh I'm just throwing it
in there so things start out yeah is
there
um one
encountered that you've pitched that
that that's like your baby encounter
that that you felt that you wanted that
we're not gonna spoil yeah I mean I mean
the answer is because you was very very
specific you knew which one I was
talking about and you was able to point
that your boy put that that one you know
it's funny at the beginning I asked him
a certain thing to where I was he's like
yeah he's like you like all these okay
he's like I did that
yeah
that's yours that you want it in and
that you got in and that's like your
baby yeah there is a a section in the
game that I'm not going to talk about
right I am extremely proud it was
probably the most challenging thing I've
ever done in my career wow but it's also
the most rewarding
um so I'm really thankful that I had the
opportunity to be able to work on it
um
a couple questions
um first thing question I have is
um you know in terms of combat
um I I want your how difficult is it to
design
lightsaber versus lightsaber combat
because I feel like that's the bread and
butter to Star Wars is that and you know
I I personally feel like those fights
seem to be the best scripted so
obviously that's because it's Star Wars
and how hard is it to really do that and
another question I have is you know
obviously this game's Canon people want
cow to be on a realistic atmosphere you
know they don't want it to be op kind of
like Starkiller and Unleashed it do you
ever get pushback if okay maybe we're
making him two Ops there is there ever
like a conversation like that because
I'm kind of curious on that because he
is Canon yeah so for the first question
we have an amazing uh boss team that on
the combat team that does all of the
those lightsaber versus lightsaber so
this is all the other bosses oh good
yeah uh they do a fantastic job it was
good epic like that's what their job is
for the whole project and they they've
they've killed it this time all right I
think there's a lot of good variety a
lot of challenges
um
but yeah I mean like it's it's a super
important thing to get right and also
trying to find that balance of because
hey lightsaber can cut through yeah like
yeah right but it's still a video game
so how do we get the feel while still
offering something that's not done in
like a couple hits unless you play New
Game Plus with the Purity oh
because let me tell y'all let's go you
want a whole new game experience really
that's how it is oh that's what to do
okay that new game plus okay all right
so yeah if you don't want to talk about
like a couple little things about New
Game Plus at some point I'm I'm all down
I'm getting for that you came for that
okay so
um yes the second question
um you know it's we we definitely try to
make sure that
there there are some things we can kind
of gamify right to make it maybe a
little bit more powerful than probably
Canon but like we try to keep it pretty
grounded as much as we as we can but you
know we will do cool things if we're
like this is an awesome experience right
but yeah because I'm sure there was you
know the developers that made it
Unleashed they have that part where
Starkiller just ripped out the destroyer
from the atmosphere and I'm sure they're
like dude that's cool and I I don't
think any of them ever thought ten years
later people like dude Stark star close
busted
uh my next question is like in terms of
lore you know you're working with
probably one of the most beloved
franchises in existence and I would say
that uh
I've seen other franchises you know uh
for example like Halo I kind of felt
like uh people who made the Halo TV show
didn't really respect the lore a whole
lot but as far as like the studio when
addressing how you're going to handle
certain things in the game because of
the lore Star Wars is there like a huge
collaboration with Lucas or are they
just at the end of the day they look at
it then they prove it
uh it I I don't I'm not as well into
that part of it
um but it is a little bit of both
sometimes we'll make some stuff and send
it over for like review and approval
sometimes
especially when we're coming up with
some story stuff there's a bit more back
and forth but uh they're they're pretty
hands off for the most part
um obviously they have the final say on
stuff because they have the bigger
picture they you know we have a lot of
Star Wars fans on the team but you know
sometimes they're just gaps in knowledge
too right so it's a it's a good back and
forth and
honestly like things that I've changed
have been like small details and not
like oh my God like you can't do do this
right so no one no one's pushed back
like you're doing too much right there
we gotta slow you down a little bit
right now exactly yeah I was actually
really surprised you put the uh the
cross card in the game because that is
in the trailer so that's not like yeah
thing but no doubt no doubt oh god let's
get
one of my next questions yeah uh since
we're talking about stuff that's in the
trailer right now I uh just want to know
who decided to make the uh Rancor this
game's version of octo bogdo and that's
super
hard to fight maybe unbeatable
uh early appearance
uh I mean so Jason the Harris is our
combat design director and he leads his
team
with uh Iron Fists
uh that was
I don't know whose decision it was to
put it there
um but like one of that's one of the
things though that we we love though
um like we want to put things for people
to explore and maybe find it too early
also because it's those moments are
super exciting when it's not scripted
and it's just based on the player so
like having something like that is super
important to have players to find I.E he
wants you to wander into a place that
you're not supporting yeah
you can get roughed up actually I'm glad
you brought that up because that was
something I've been thinking about while
playing this game so far it has an
excellent sense of Discovery because
you can see like the general area of the
map and if you turn on like the
navigation assist it does help you
figure out where you can go but unless
it's a Mainline Quest it doesn't
necessarily push you in that way and I
not entirely sure if this ties into like
the encounter design but I do want to
ask if you had any insight into that
sense of discovery that this game is
very good about instilling into the
player yeah so that that's definitely
our level design team like straight up
you know there is a lot of stuff that
resonated well in fall and order like
the the venerator crash on zepho and you
know being able to go to uh dathomir
early yeah
yeah exactly I did find the the double
blade the double that was my highlight I
got what I want I'll I'll need to be
here
exactly because you like you know those
types of experiences were a huge
influence I I know talking to some
people and like they wanted to make sure
that all the side content was really
meaningful even in small ways too like
not everything has to be this big like
dungeon for lack of a better word but
like you know it can be just like oh
here's this cool path with a fun little
encounter and a cool reward yeah it
feels like it's part of the world right
no that's awesome man and that that's
the the beauty of it like like Logan I
was talking about it does open up that
sense of Discovery even if you have a
navigation assist or whatever it does
make me go I know the gays wanted me to
go here yeah there's some stuff over
there yeah that's me like I'm like I'm
not interested in you game I think
there's some stuff over there I could
get some skill points I can still level
up okay the the way that they gave him
new traversal elements that makes him
very oh yeah it it feels real soon
the movement yeah I try not to use any
of the the first Fallen order I didn't
know you could upgrade your healing
stick stems and I had three almost the
entire game oh my God man and I got to
it I got to a a fight towards the end of
the game you guys are I'm sure you guys
could tell me which one it is it was the
uh it was the circled set through Terror
it was like love everywhere that dude I
almost beat him twice and I was like
dude there's got to be some I don't know
what's going on like because I it felt
so punishing it's like he hits me one
time I'm almost dead you felt like how I
felt when I played Final Fantasy remake
and I didn't know to that to move over
the cura and the stronger versions of
the bad and I'm using basic I've used yo
Pat I use basic Cura from the beginning
to the end saffron fights and I'm like
I'm literally everything five seconds
doing the pause all right heal heal and
then somebody's like God you know you
just moved the directional pad to the
side and there's the stronger versions
and I'm like I literally made it a Souls
encounter every fight from the beginning
like it was great so it's interesting to
hear addict say that about you know what
you call a Jedi because you know say
like yeah I remember seeing that one to
the side where it's like okay increase
stem you know BD you know to give you
more energy more health and stuff like
that so those are little key things to
kind of look out for I love
um in Survivor when you sit down to
meditate I thought it was going to be
the same meditation screen I thought it
was going to be you know it's kind of
the same meditation trees
no like graphically the stuff popped up
yeah and I was like oh they they they're
going deeper into it and they they kept
some of the same acidics from the
previous one to keep you comfortable but
speaking at somebody who's uh girlfriend
is playing through Skyrim you are a
hundred percent
we got to ask some more questions I want
to jump in in reference to obviously how
to games performing you know the reviews
currently doing pretty well Stella like
sitting about 86 Metacritic but we got
to talk about the elephant in the room
or you know so Patrick about the
performance you know now I know you guys
dropped a day one patch you know but we
still have heard multiple reports of
people especially on PC really having
serious issues
okay
some people want you know they want to
show off their bills they wanted to get
over there y'all got the premium
experience a little slanted a PC Mastery
you know that's it but look you don't
respect that
it's one of those things that sucks
right yeah
nobody wants to play a game that's
performing bad we don't want people
playing a game that's playing bad
um
gain like and I'm not this isn't more of
making excuses or anything because I
think everyone saw the tweet that we put
out yes it's being worked on like we
acknowledge that but like games are so
much more complex I've noticed
especially within the past five years
and there's so many more PC
configurations and like I didn't even
realize this until I really started
working like harder on PC that just two
different PC components can be
incompatible with one another in a way
that just makes the game Run bad not our
game just just in general like I
remember a time where my buddy and I I
forgot what game it was a couple years
ago where we're gonna play co-op and we
both had pretty similar specs same video
card but like a different CPU played
fine on mine stuttered all the time on
his and he couldn't play it's just like
it's so so difficult and you know we
work we work really hard we have a lot
of smart people working on it you know
more patches are coming so no doubt you
know the the performance will get better
I I 100 believe that yeah it's it does
suck that it was not where it is no I
respect your answering that again I'm
not playing what I say is yeah but by
the um console version Oh my God where
I'm not having that problem because I
have vrr and you know I was sitting
there like I really I was like what the
hell are they talking about this game is
running beautifully uh I put it in
quality mode I'm like this is incredible
I put it in performance mode I said this
is mind-blowing and then I heard the PC
dudes talking about the the frame rate I
said well you got to tweak and Twerk it
you got to tweak it for it
lower the resolution and you got to get
into it but listen I can give you a
suggestion Wale they're patching up your
version oh go go buy series access
or buy PlayStation five and buy the game
there so while they're patching up your
stuff over there you can you can play in
good resolutions oh my God and have such
a great time I mean I know Patrick can't
say it um so buy two copies that you can
fix up and the one that you can actually
tweak it and twerking
[Music]
but what I want to say is that you know
I do like obviously we know hopefully
the patches are coming and um that Talib
I definitely need that VR on patch to
take take advantage yeah don't buy TV
please relay that to the team you know
saying but um what I did want to there
was a comment that was made and
referenced it before because I want to
know if you agree or not Patrick this is
accurate this is from uh Dale Harris
he's a senior uh character artist at
Naughty Dog currently he was previously
at respawn so he said when making the
game for a console you're making it for
one set of drivers and Hardware when
making a game for PC you're making it
for like 900 plus possible combinations
something can really look and feel ready
until you release it to millions of
people developers are trying really hard
but it's not easy when dealing with
unstandardized platforms especially with
how complex and graphically intense
modern video games are do you agree with
this statement yeah definitely I mean I
I kind of hinted at that earlier with
you know my experience with your plane
a game with trying to play a game with
my friend with two different slightly
different computers right
um yeah and so yeah drivers is actually
a whole nother issue like you can have
the same exact computer set up with
people on different drivers one person
can be fine and another person can be
just like crashing every 10 seconds not
fair enough it's crazy you know and like
we like we have compatibility teams and
are testing on multiple stuff but like
yeah there is just that many components
or something no no doubt Lord condo you
have something else on this before I did
want to ask uh since we're on the like
technical uh
part of this discussion uh at least
between uh PlayStation and Xbox which
seemed to have the uh
more difficult uh technical issues to
resolve in development
I don't know how better to describe it
but
I didn't have as much insight into this
um for this especially
like being on the Xbox for so long for
so for Halo like you know I've been so
used to just working on one platform
um
you know I think they're they this
generation in particular is pretty
comparable which makes it very nice you
know it's a very small differences like
I I heard like there's just like how
memory is managed has to be slightly
different per console but like there's
not like I worked on a 360 and PS3 game
back in the day and man that when you
want to talk about like different
consoles and which one's more difficult
like the PS3 is a nightmare for
multi-platform back in the day where
it's really not that anymore it's more
of like small smaller trade-offs right
yeah you know what Patrick's look like
right there in that scene right there
there he looked like Neo you know when
they were shooting at him on the roof
and he was like
you can answer the question yeah
he said you're not gonna give me what
that question is
you gotta find it
yeah you say you know what
um the difference is very minute you
know it's just a little memory thing
they're pretty much the same they both
have the same problems next
what's funny is when he said that I
almost I came this close to say and
that's a question we avoid
but I had to watch I had to watch the
boys outside I was thinking about it in
my head and the moment that it came I
was like Oh no
you're good you're good shout out shout
out PS5 the little controller features
and BD talking to you through the
computer kind of sweet kind of sweet
cake and I wouldn't know that
when I play Death clue I missed out like
two hours of the game because I didn't
know I didn't realize homegirls speaking
in the controller well I didn't hear her
at all
but he's talking to someone no one's
talking back and I thought it was buggy
one question I want to ask you this kind
of different in reference to remote work
this has come up a lot I'm seeing in
reference to gain development I know
you're a big proponent of it you know
respawn from my understanding you know
in this particular case you're able to
kind of get this sequel out in less than
three years is that accurate because oh
about three years or so three and a half
uh following order was November 2019.
this is end of April 2023. right yeah so
my question is you know we're seeing
game development time sometimes take a
bit longer you know taking something in
that four or five year range you know
and one thing people I'm seeing is like
okay some people are like hey we love
the fact that we have the convenience
the ability to work from home to be
remote that's a huge advantage to get
more people to join the team than other
people I'm speaking to in the industry
will say well that is a convenience but
there's some people like hey it you lose
the ability to say okay if Patrick's
right in the room with me and his team
right then and then we may not have to
play tag phone tags or telephone so as
much and some things take longer like
where do you sit on that because correct
me
you were able to go into the office but
now at least when you're kind of remote
like what do you like better or what do
you think about game development as a
whole with remote work really being more
a part of it
yeah it's a great question uh I mean I
I'm a huge proponent of remote work I
think it opens up a ton more
opportunities like I wouldn't be working
on I didn't work on Jedi survivors there
was no remote work in another like World
um personally like yeah I I would like a
hybrid approach like I'd like to be able
to go in the office like for a day or
two to like you know do some meetings
get some face-to-face time but like
there's so much in game development that
you can do from home now but it's like
going from a hybrid Approach at 343 to
remote for me personally has definitely
been a challenge because yeah you have
to learn new ways of communication you
have to make sure you know you write
documentation different ways like it's
you know there are adjustments and
um I think in terms of like when you
look at the industry with like different
game development times and stuff
just some some companies have done a
better job adapting to that and some
haven't
um you know being able to work it unreal
with it being a more public engine
there's a lot more tools for that some
proprietary Tech out there you all of a
sudden have to rewrite a bunch of stuff
or add a bunch of things to make work
you know about proprietary engines yeah
exactly continue
this is Unreal Engine 4 right yeah this
is unreal four it looks absolutely
absolutely gorgeous I want to get you
down to this to the magic moment where
we are right which is you know giant
Survivor you know you being a big Star
Wars fan personally yeah a huge Star
Wars fan and then a lot of people don't
realize you actually worked on a Star
Wars game before was it Star Wars uh
first assault yep it's called Sunrise
first itself the game that never was
that never came right so this is kind of
I would say like a Redemption story and
it says like you're such a Star Wars fan
you worked on something back in days of
Lucas or that didn't come out you know
you go full circle through here and like
you're part of a team that is now
arguing a Couture fans don't come for me
what I'm about to say but
arguably one of the best Star Wars games
ever you can make top two top three
arguments Kotor fans I know there's a
lot of you I respect y'all you know what
I'm saying Jedi is giving I feel I know
you down with the code to our team too
so but Jedi's giving that feel that
being an addict talked about like that
that game of the year type feel and
energy of what this game is so like
where you actually would put this a
little bit below uh not slow Republic
okay you got it close though do you you
got it yeah and I think I think because
because the only reason I'm like not 100
there is because I feel like comparing
the two is unreal is unfair because
Knights of the Republic's so old like I
feel like if you put that into a newer
setting it would level the like Revenue
yeah this is a better game than not the
Republic but I feel like that's a fair
it's a fair comparison all I would say
is we have to say the history of Star
Wars games as a whole
as you look at all wouldn't all of them
be considered great right so it
basically the investors okay what do you
think of that fighting game
[Laughter]
yeah yeah you know
I received refrained but yeah but for me
personally it's always you know the cold
tours and now surviving the reason why I
have to throw you know Jedi photo on the
Jedi Survivor in the conversation is
because these characters are so beloved
you know cow cast this bd1 the whole
thing say like it is so like it feels
like it literally should have its own
like we should be getting out into the
movie spare and the the you know what
I'm saying that no I agree cow deserves
his own TV
show that's the only thing I'm saying
and again I'm putting respect on code
towards them not being disciplined but
they might work their way to it because
in between stuff if Cal isn't part of
that Master Plan movie that they're
making where all of them to come
together I'm a riot like I'm a rock
because because you know obviously the
the the the story lines are a little off
but it's like you know unless they plan
on killing this dude off in the future
like I believe in cow
too so again imagine okay oh real quick
imagine after like Survivor if like
Disney finds like the amount of people
that love this character and they
they do a TV like a Disney plush show of
him after all the movies oh that'd be
kind of Fire
I kind of fight so that's what my why I
was getting that role of this is you
know just try to put everything in the
pantheon right the proper pattern and
now that you've come full circle you
worked on a Star Wars game didn't come
out but now you're on this like has it
sunk in to be part of this greatness of
one of your favorite franchise I think
it's starting to it definitely didn't
like a couple days ago it's like oh it's
out like it happened but um I think it's
starting to
um like you said like this being part of
this team in particular couldn't have
asked for a better team to land on to
develop a Star Wars game
um like
for a little bit of History actually for
me because I think
I think it's important to kind of talk
about these Journeys because like we
always you know show the good on social
media all the time but I actually
applied
three times for this team over the years
wow uh so back when respawn announced
they're working on a Star Wars game
before has announced Jedi Fallen order I
applied to uh a level design position uh
did some interviews they I had just
first person shooter experience you know
they were looking for third person
action so it didn't work out but like
and then
you know try it again early 2021
uh for technical design role and came
really close to getting that
um and I'm really glad that I did that
interview because later when this
encounter design position opened they're
like we think it would actually be a
really good fit for this
um and so I interviewed for that and was
able to get it but like part I want to
talk about that is like
you know I got two rejections right you
know and
sometimes like it's just not the right
place right time and story right yeah
failures part of the process let's go
this is Jed I talk let's go back exactly
and so and it like I am so happy to be
in the role that I'm in though because
of like this was
for me is the perfect role for what I do
no doubt super proud of you brother well
Patrick ain't saying he he sent the
email was like I'm Gonna Keep applying
every year
he just didn't take it personally you
know and it was part of the process and
he just went back got stronger in the
force and came back
the position that is perfect for you he
got you know he leveled his skill tree
out he was back it was all listen man
I'm super proud of you the reason why
it's it's impressive to me is that you
know from your past like again we're
gonna get into it like you've created
one of the most fun part of the creation
of one of the most fun multiplayer
sandboxes right in the Halo infinite and
then they come into a single player game
you know and being an encounter design
that's a big shift and that is something
worth praising from from a skill set
perspective we gonna give you your
flowers on that like that is impressive
you know I mean especially being quality
in both areas so I don't care what
nobody said this got that game in the
efl I'm just saying yeah
anyway
like I said previously you know most of
the realm are familiar with with your
past right as far as where you came from
obviously Halo infinite obviously that
sandbox you know saying you had a part
on on Fret as far as um multiplayer
seven I love Fred by the way Fred is
hilarious that's great yeah when you run
it around all right guys watch out oh be
careful like he's just so nervous energy
he's the one I rock with all the times I
remember we talked about you know
obviously your role in that and then
things so I wanted to get into as far as
like Halo infinite and obviously there
were some comments that you you made you
know about what what's going on and but
one thing I respect about you was your
brutal honesty about it and um when it
came to the way you feel Halo infinite
was handled obviously you know the
layoffs obviously you know based on
comments about leadership and then that
the layoff shouldn't have happened and
develop a stress overall during that
time when you know the devs would try to
push to make Halo a better game for the
community so looking back do you still
stand on those comments regarding the
mismanagement 343 and also what did you
personally take from your time at 343 I
I mean yeah I I wouldn't have made those
conferences oh he's standing on him so
um you know there's obviously a lot that
I can't talk about
um but like I'm not gonna say that three
four three was all bad I had some
wonderful
times there made some that's some
wonderful people made some incredible
friends you know that I'm
I'm I mean like later it says something
when later in life you meet someone at
work and they're part of your wedding
you know so but um but yeah but there
was obviously a lot of missteps
um
it felt it always felt like my job was
harder than it needed to be of all of
our jobs um
so you know there are certain things I
wish I could talk more I'm proud of what
we ship for Halo infinite but also
know that like
it should have been more I respect that
I respect that yeah I respect you stood
on it and and again you know in your
defense you know a lot of people agreed
with you and actually echoed some of the
statements as far as things needing to
change there and hopefully you know with
new leadership and and and the comments
that were made that this would get a
chance for them to course correct be in
delivery because I've always said
regardless to the issue being I felt as
far as the delivery of consistent live
service content I've always said the
core gameplay from a multiplayer sandbox
is excellent you know what I mean the
actual when we came added when we fire
this thing up we do community streams
game great so salute to you for making
the comment standing on your square and
again you know obviously you know you
probably wish the team the best in your
former colleagues that's still there 100
hopefully they could deliver it here's
like the the one last thing I'll say Get
it nobody wants to make a bad game
like everyone wants to make something
that's awesome that people are going to
enjoy and like
I've only met like maybe one lazy Dev in
my life but well like you know you see
those comments as a developer it's just
like
I don't understand like you're upset but
let me tell you like people ain't being
lazy
and talk dad so I feel and that's why I
love these kind of conversations because
again you get it from the horse's mouth
you get to understand how things work
and a lot of times in game is we get it
wrong we think all they got to do is
flip the switch you know put it on the
switch
that's a lot of development work
shout out to the switch again
oh man anyway before we before we wrap I
just want to make sure everyone got some
more additional questions added King
gondo I see you cooking the condo what
you got yeah something I've been really
wanting to ask about uh
how much did uh your team work on a
certain mini game in Survivor that
you're rewarded for oh you are rewarded
with extra parts to play this game with
by playing the rest of the game yeah I
mean like we had a core team working on
that the whole time so like like we we
have like a really awesome Tech design
team that really takes these types of
like systems and uh you know just runs
with them like somebody had an idea to
do this and just ran with it right and
to your point the reason why I love that
mini game is it you know play it plays
into itself with just playing the game
right like you're rewarded for going out
and like doing certain things in the
game that then you can get to do in this
mini game that then gives you rewards
for the for the actual game right yeah
like out of the 13 hours I've played at
least an hour and a half maybe two hours
of them have been spent uh losing to
scuba stev you know what's funny
you know how much I don't care about
side stuff oh man absolutely no idea
what they're talking about oh wow
whatsoever you gotta give this a chance
is there are there any rewards for him
for this so they can incentivize yes
there are Cosmetics that's not called
Cosmetics
resources to buy gameplay
[Music]
you're pretty far you don't say before
you wrap up yeah uh Patrick told me I'm
like the last stretch like the last
chapter
you know it's and I could already tell
what's about to happen because uh it was
kind of dropped uh so it's it's
interesting man one thing I will say is
um
I do feel like if it wasn't the
performance issues of this game I do
think it would have been a 90 plus
Metacritic game like that's how good it
is like people that saying the
PlayStation version wasn't like
wasn't hit too much for the performance
issues I I disagree I think we're just
talking about like uh upper echelon game
got hit down a couple because of the
performance but I still think it it
that 87 isn't Justified I I think this
game is a Higher One than that no doubt
no doubt over here other questions with
Jedi related before we uh close up not
really
um I just like the fact that uh you know
the game is at least two to three times
greater than the first one and if that's
telling you that a lot of people thought
the first one could have been game of
the year that's letting you know that
this one is in contention for game of
the year and then in a year where we're
going to have a ton of great games come
out
it should be uh fighting for that top
spot at the end from the from
the little bit that I've played because
once a Gondor said he paid 13 hours I'm
just like okay bro yeah
you see and these individuals all right
so let's push those guys to the side if
I wouldn't have went if I wouldn't have
watched watched the Evil Dead last night
I probably would have finished this
morning I ran out of time
the abnormal guy that's the abnormal guy
that they're abnormal and all right so
I'm the normal guy I'm I'm like four to
five hours and all right so normal guys
normal things playing at a normal place
um I've just noticed like the textures
on the clothing I put I put it on the
widest view yes I'm playing yeah I have
a lot of gas please and I'm looking at
the distance I'm trying to break the
engine right because I'm hearing that
these individuals talking about they're
having performance issues I'm looking at
a distance I'm saying wow you can see
all the way in the distance from no
pop-up and then the foliage distance uh
the it's the LOD is really crazy that is
that that foliage goes that far out and
I'm then I'm looking down into because
I'm using BD as the telescope and I'm
looking into the landscape and I'm doing
just things as a gamer right and I'm
appreciating the hard work that y'all
get y'all went into with the textures
and the level design and I'm looking at
the just the first world that I'm able
to get into
and I said man this game if it and it
will live up to expectations because I
see the the banter that I have with the
NPCs and they're giving me quests and
I'm like yo it's turning into a action
RPG slight action RPG type of feel with
it exploratory uh elements to it
and it keeps me enthused so the fact
that you're able to keep those
encounters happening that's why I'm so
um like curious about the encounters
with the way that I'm able to Traverse
the world in the way that you and your
team is perfect purposefully
um placing encounters around the world
to keep you uh having a good time I
gotta say you did a great job because at
no point in time that I feel like the
world was Barren that I didn't have
anything to do with something around
every corner and you guys really nailed
that fun aspect of it I think you were
supposed to you're supposed to have uh
for every three to five steps you're
supposed to have like uh three to two
minutes of encounter time how did y'all
do that like manage the time between
encounters and to make it feel like it's
something constantly happening
definitely a really good question
for kind of the the stuff I give a shout
out to uh lee who like built that system
and really really made it like come to
life no doubt one thing I will will you
know give your whole team props on
everyone at respawn is like
I like how you guys are able to make you
feel like you're in a huge War but
you're not in a huge War like you'd be
going through and there'll be Tie
fighters fighting shooting each other
down and like realistically ain't none
of that smoke for you and it ain't never
gonna be for you but you it's it's like
an illusion belt that it's like look at
all this nice stuff up here by the time
you get to us we all being we we're done
but it gives a nice immersion